el ataque al embajador italiano tuvo
lugar a unos 10 km de la ciudad de goma
esto es en la zona este de la república
democrática del congo el embajador
italiano se encontraba a bordo de un
vehículo parte de un convoy del programa
mundial de alimentos este convoy cayó en
una emboscada hombres armados bloquearon
el vehículo y asesinaron primero al
chofer y después al guardaespaldas
italiano y finalmente hirieron
gravemente al embajador italiano quien
murió posteriormente en un hospital de
la zona el ataque por el momento no ha
sido reivindicado la muerte de este
embajador de 43 años ha generado aquí en
italia una ola de profunda consternación
italia está de luto esto dijo el
presidente italiano sergio matar el a el
jefe del gobierno mario draghi manifestó
su solidaridad a las familias del
embajador y de sus acompañantes y la
fiscalía de roma ha abierto una
investigación este martes un equipo de
policías investigadores italianos
llegarán a kinshasa la capital de la
república
democrática del congo